But it was the craziest thing ever seen my, so when, uh,
my kid's mom, her father died like suddenly, so my kids' grandpa died suddenly.
Right. Really horrible thing.
We go to this funeral home on fourth Avenue in Brooklyn,
and it's this old school, like Italian guy. So like my kid's mom, she asked me,
she was like, look like, can you please negotiate? Like with the funeral guy,
like she was sitting right there. And I was like, yeah, whatever, you know,
whatever you need. Cause she saw us. Yeah. The cost and this guy like so well,
you know, he's like, uh, all right. I, you know, I, sorry for your guys' loss.
He goes, listen, he goes, um, you know what what's,
what was the man who passed away? What was his political affiliation?
I swear to God. And I'm like, I don't know if that, you know, whatever,
but he was a huge Donald Trump. So, so I, so my kid's,
mom's looking at me and I'm like, you know, and then until I say, you know what,
he, he voted for Trump and he goes out, man,
that man out there voted for Donald Trump. And I said, yeah. And he goes,
listen to me. He goes, here's what we're going to do. He goes,
the cost of the funeral is 4,000. He goes right now it's 2000. I swear to God.
I swear to God. He goes, he goes, listen. He goes, here's what I want to do.
Because as he died, because Trump's November of 2016,
this guy died January of 2017. So there weren't a lot of big Trump. Got it.
She's like, here's what we're going to do. He goes, we want to put,
I want to put, uh, uh, make America great again,
Donald Trump wreath in the casket, that's on our funeral home.
And my kid's mom was like, no, please don't do that. He goes,
let me put a make America great again, hat you just kept going.
And then she kept saying, no, she kept saying, no, dude,
when we put him in the ground, he had a make America great again,
pin on his suit. And then he starts going. He goes, yeah. He goes,
thank God. He goes, some people got sense. He goes,
it's unfortunate that we just have to lose a guy who voted for the right guy.
He goes, I had a family in here yesterday. He goes, and I'm talking to him.
And it's funny that he's even mentioning this while people are grieving.
He goes not talking to them. He goes and they just buried whoever.
That's what he said goes, they just buried whoever. And he goes,
and I asked him, who do you vote for? Or they told me, I voted for Hillary.
And I said, give me one good reason. Give me one good reason.
I think was not something that Anderson Cooper said. He goes,
give me one buck a good reason why you would vote for Hillary and why.
And tell me one thing that Trump hasn't done that hasn't been fantastic for
this country. Just one thing, not. Real facts.
Just tell me one thing Trump's done wrong in these last two months. And he said,
I told them if they could tell me what Trump did wrong,
I'd give them the funeral half off. And he goes, guess what?
They paid full price.
And then he just, you know,
and then we just buried this guy and he was just there the whole time he was
offering everybody coffee. He's like this. He was telling me he was like,
he voted for Trump. He won, he got the, um, I think her father,
her father did fight in the army or didn't I think he
did, but there was like a problem. But anyway, he still had like the full, like,
you know, medal of honor, you know, saxophone, American flag thing.
And I already know, and he just did that.
I don't even know if like legally he was allowed to do that, but he just did it.
Cause he bought it for Trump. He was like,
it's an American hero one way or another. And then he goes,
anybody ever dies in your family? You come to Nate.